some 600 miles east of Moscow a new
facility in the town of yalabuga is
getting ready to ramp up Russia's
production of drones the White House
says the plants will manufacture Iranian
drones with operations starting as soon
as early 2024.
Russia's invasion of Ukraine showed how
inexpensive unmanned aerial vehicles or
uavs were effective on the battlefield
for reconnaissance and for attacks
Aviation experts say unlike Ukraine
Russia's use of unmanned systems got off
to a slow start here's how Moscow is
catching up in the drain Race by
building up arsenals of low-cost
explosive drones
early in the war Russia mostly relied on
conventional military uavs
reconnaissance strains like this Orlan
have been effective as spotting targets
and calling in artillery fire but these
systems are relatively expensive costing
around 100
000 in units and Military experts with
CNA and American defense research
organization believe Russian forces had
a limited number of these uavs with
plans to significantly ramp up
production in 2023
meanwhile Ukrainian troops started using
cheap modified commercial drones for
surveillance and to destroy valuable
Russian equipment early on
as The Invasion turned into a war of
attrition Moscow realized its need for
low-cost explosive drones in mid-2022
Moscow started importing Iranian Shahid
drones to Target's Ukrainian
infrastructure CNA expert Samuel Bandit
estimated the price tag for the Shah
heads to be under 50 000 each which
makes it cost effective for Russia to
use and with this new plant Russia will
be able to produce some 6 000 Iranian
design drones on his territory in the
coming years according to officials from
a country aligned with the US
but Shah heads can only navigate to
pre-programmed targets
so in response to Ukraine's
counter-offensive Russia has been
increasingly using domestically produced
Lancet drones which are flown by pilots
in real time
in July Russian State media reported
from what it said was a former shopping
mall that was turned into our plans to
assemble lancets Russia's defense
Ministry has increasingly reported on
the small uavs damaging Ukrainian
weapons including arms supplied by the
West
in August Vladimir Putin asked for the
production of lances to increase
it's not clear how many of these joints
Russia has last October Russian pro-war
bloggers put the number at 1 500 units
Kiev has acknowledged the challenges
posed by Russian drones such as lancets
and orlands to its forces on the
battlefield the Ukrainian government
says the vehicles rely on foreign made
Parts some imported from the West the
chief of staff to the Ukrainian
presidents called for more sanctions on
Russian drone producers and stricter
controls over components exports
military experts agree that sourcing
components is a major issue for the
Russian drain industry but if Russia
still manages to quickly ramp up
production of low-cost drones this could
spell trouble for Ukrainian forces